I make the frosting
did you shoot that face at him
[Music]
I'm practically insane
[Applause]
[Music]
guys absolute Alerus I washed it was a
kid he made me laugh my ass off
my dad came in the room I did change the
channel because he's like what are you
laughing about I'm like you'll never
understand old man I'll never understand
ladies John you might know him from
baskets please give it up mr. Louie
Anderson everybody I'm from a family of
11 and I know that's what people always
say women always Wow and I'm not the
first celebrity in our house my brother
the safecracker
he was the first celebrity cuz he was a
really you know pretty good safecracker
so anyways when you're doing that when
you have that kind of family member they
become these kind of celebrities in
their own right you know like my brother
brought me a brand new bike then I never
had a bike any comedy give my parents
money we were super poor we were so poor
that I gave my mom a coupon book for her
birthday I'll wash the dishes I'll do
the laundry
I'll kill dad for you
Louie you wouldn't really kill your
father would you I would for you ma
there's no expiration date on the coupon
and one day I came home from school I
thought it was all over with my dad goes
areas hitman Louie you're gonna kill me
Howry
Here I am I remember I remember I was 10
years old something like Tom and the FBI
came to her house and that's a weird
thing right there you know cuz the FBI
you just don't think they're gonna show
up you just just oh you never think if
somebody said tell me who you think's
gonna show up it's way down on the list
it's way
after ATF so I was home ten you know
that's how I talked about his ten what
and you know when you're 10 in a family
of 11 you have you're told to shut up
all the time what are you guys doing
shut up they do that fake move toward
you ooh you have to learn not to flinch
you have to go cuz I don't know why this
is but when you flinch they get to punch
up you realize they make up these rules
that's it
that's why I can't move this arm up any
higher it's true so the FBI comes to our
house and I go downstairs because I'm
the door answer god I gotta put some
pants on he's never had anything but
boxers and a t-shirt who's ready for
summer
they come I go up there what son not
your son we'd like to talk to your
parents
what a ball son I'm not your son could
you get your father dad there's Mormons
here they come
men they go they say to him sir
yeah my dad yeah we're the FBI
yes so FBI ha you got my letters huh is
he used to write letters of the
government all the time but my mom would
usually intercept them or we would dear
mom look read this we'd like to come in
I'm sure you would I'm a veteran you
know well thank you for your service
yeah
what do you want we're here with the
search warrant we were looking for your
son well he's not here yeah he's not
here
want to leave them alone that was my
whole stance for the whole thing won't
you leave him alone
you didn't do it and then my mom comes
out of the kitchen in the sweetest
person in the world you love her
what's going on here who's here my dad
g-man g-man I'll never forget that g-man
and she goes what it's the FBI they want
to go looking for your son it's her son
oh well I haven't seen him but come on
in boys would you like a nice cup of
coffee
my dad grumbles oh why don't you ask him
to stay over well maybe I will so my mom
brings him in do you like Folgers it's
good to the last drop so they come in my
mom very smart now this must be a
terrible job huh
cuz nobody's ever happy to see you are
they well not really men well it must be
terrible would you like a nice piece of
chocolate cake it's Duncan Hines I make
the frosting first don't you shoot that
face at him
I'm practically insane that's my husband
that's why so she cuts him the cake and
it was the best cake seriously she goes
can you guess what's in the ingredients
to the frosting Oh God we play in the
feud they go Wow chocolate that's right
sugar mmm and that's it isn't it no you
know what I put in there a tiny splash
tell your wives about it so they're
they're my brothers they're my other
brothers they're my dad's in there
[Music]
there's a noisy dad well we better get
looking we'd like to execute the warrant
right now they're gonna kill them no son
I'm not your son and then so they start
looking now this is the thing about our
house like my mom was a pack rat you
know a bad one not a hoarder though cuz
we had aisles anyway so they go to the
basement first and my mom is the best
she goes when you're down there if you
find a saucer that'll match this Cup
will you bring it up
hello every mom she's lovely crazy so
they're down there they're sweating when
they come up you know like I am right
now and they come up and honestly
they're just like Oh God
well there's four more bedrooms to look
through and they go okay so there we
start going I'm B I'm right behind the
FBI will you get paid for this Ming a
lot of money you ever shoot anyone I
can't discuss that you did done I'm not
stupid
you guys should take my dad he steals
napkins
that's what Reed used to do he come out
of a restaurant and he'd go
now my brother's there he's upstairs we
hit him in the hall closet under about a
thousand pounds of clothes anyway so
they get through to get to the closet
the big closet there's a big giant
closet in the hall they opened the doors
he's not here
you know I'm 10 I'm nervous now he's not
here
of telegraphy the whole figured my
brother
they start poking around in there he
didn't do it I was with them we were
fishing at night
we're night fishing so they're going
through the closet and you know that the
clothes are up to there and you know
when you dig through clothes there's
something creepy about it don't you
think when they're not your clothes
there's something where you go you know
and they're moving it around the guys
look at each other and go let's go down
have another piece of that cake and they
go downstairs and have cake and coffee
and my mom's talking to well boys how's
your mother doing she says dude oh she's
good tell her I said and they have
another piece of cake and my dad
whispers to my other brother that's all
I could hear and then my brother gets in
our Buick and screeches out of there and
of course just reflex the FBI jump up
run out and get in their car and go
after them and then my brother throws
the clothes off and comes down the
stairs and goes out the back door and
escapes and my mom goes that cake is
good isn't it
[Applause]
and that's my family and my brother the
great thing is that my brother turned
his life around and he started you know
teaching the police he started telling
them basically how dumb they were that's
what he explained to me but I love my
brother and myths of mine I dedicate
this show to
[Applause]
[Music]